there's no end in sight to the crime
wave rocking america
murders and shootings are surging coast
to coast
and states like california are becoming
the epicenter of other types of
lawlessness
where they have basically legalized
theft police say shoplifters in l.a
didn't even bother to run they just
casually walked out of a store carrying
a bunch of clothes
and we've seen this happen before in san
francisco when thieves looted a
different high-end department store in
broad daylight
law enforcement is blaming scenes like
this on proposition 47
which lowers jail sentences for
shoplifting on
theft less than 950 dollars worth of
goods
california governor gavin newsom was
grilled about that specific
law today but he says it's not to blame
the evidence doesn't back it up the last
three decades we've actually seen a
significant decline in
crime in the state you're seeing crime
increase in red states
that had no criminal justice reform
commensurate with the crime rates
that we're seeing here in california
particularly relates to gun related
crimes so
i think that's an easy scapegoat for
folks people that never supported those
initiatives in the first place
but business owners and employees that
have to deal with this surge and theft
are calling as bluff it's just
lawlessness off people are just
uh openly just coming in and stealing
stuff people don't want to leave their
stuff
out because they're afraid somebody's
going to snatch it and grab it
i see two to three four or five cars up
and down the street getting broken into
in broad daylight and people walk out
with stuff and
police don't do it greg i know you have
something very exciting to say because
you told me earlier
so i'm sure is gavin newsom being
that cynically i don't know or stupid
that the crime is going down simply
because they're not processing it
is it that obvious as you see these
numbers and say no we don't have any
stats on it because you're no longer
keeping the stats
by the way when you watch these guys
leave it is kind of funny
it's like they're boarding a flight
they're they're so cat and they're the
only thing they're
kind of concerned about is that their
bags may not fit in the overhead bin
but they look just like me boarding and
you know in uh uh
group one of course only group one all
right there's a weird bait and switch
going on with this
this crime wave if you bring up the
violent crime wave
the democrats will immediately say not
all democrats but
most of them will say it's a local
problem and pull a pontius pilot like oh
it's a local problem the police can
handle it but then they will turn around
and with a straight face look into a
camera and say
gun violence is a national epidemic
right so the criminal the criminal act
is a local problem but the weapon is a
national problem
and i'm trying to figure out why would
they do that is that i mean in my brain
i'm going they want the crime to proceed
while disarming the public is that why
they're doing it and i'm trying to think
who would do that and i was thinking
about what
what harold said yesterday which was the
truth was like every normal person
democrat and republican
alike black and white is against crime
we all
everybody like nobody wants it so who is
behind this
and i i who is behind the idea that law
and order is a detriment to the world's
greatest country and it has to be this
elite
activist class we have radicals in our
country
who realize that if you want to just in
order to
remake society first you have to destroy
it and they realize destroying it from
within
by marrying racial warfare to the
concept of justice
prevents politicians and anybody from
actually trying to protect themselves
because that will be seen as
an act of racism because law and order
now is fundamentally racist
this is why when you when you listen to
the business owners and you listen to
law enforcement they keep saying
we've never seen this before we don't
this is
so strange and crazy to see such brazen
crime
and that's because it's an internal
mutiny of of of moral and civil order
this is something that is new it's scary
and i hate using the phrase slippery
slope because it's
it's a cliche but i i don't think i
think that there is no
it just keeps going i don't see the stop
on this
no especially you prevent people katie
from protecting themselves
that's what you try to do is that even
at the local level you have gun control
measures that are put in place
to create criminals out of non-violent
citizens and residents who are simply
trying to protect themselves
you saw it in virginia and that's why
again
it's all about guns but you're more and
more removing people's ability to
protect themselves and their families
but it's worse than that because
these politicians have removed on the
local and federal level
a number of ways that americans can
protect themselves and now if you
live in a place even where you are
legally allowed to own a firearm and you
defend yourself
you are the one who is vilified rather
than the criminal who may break into
your home
or into your house and the prosecutors
who have been elected and backed by
these
big left-wing activists or the ones who
are prosecuting law-abiding citizens who
simply just want
criminals to leave them alone and the
worst part of it is these
mayors and these congresswomen and
congressmen who
are for the defund the police movement
who are on these city councils who
defended the police for these
communities
and they use taxpayer dollars for their
own personal security for private
security while they make the rest of
these people live in this crime-ridden
awful scenario where they have no one to
turn to and they think well even if i
call the police
the prosecutors aren't going to keep
them in jail so it will be continuing to
be
a problem but on the issue of the
businesses it's horrible to watch
people walking out of tj maxx which is a
corporation with hundreds of dollars
worth of stuff but what if you're a guy
who
has a bodega or you're a small business
where you're an immigrant who came here
with nothing from another country and
you started a business
and this is the way that you're being
treated and there is nobody in
government no politicians who are
willing to stand up for you and say
enough is enough we're not going to let
your life savings and your life's work
be wiped out by a bunch of criminals
because we are incompetent in past
these propositions that allow crime to
continue and and that's who i think
about and i think the people who work in
tj maxx are minimum wage who are trying
to earn
an honest living who have to watch these
guys come in in this criminality and
walk out the door and eventually it just
feels
really hopeless and these politicians
continue to put people
in these horrible positions they won't
try to stop them they've actually been
told here in new york city
don't stop anybody who's trying to
shoplift i see people shoplifting from
my local drugstore all the time
because if you put your hands on someone
they scream rape they scream
racism and the like the upside down
logic of what you hear
harold from the the democrats
is that here you'll say oh if you
prosecute shoplifting if you treat
theft as a crime then that's
criminalizing poverty because poor
people need to steal
however what happens is the more you let
people steal these businesses go away
they disappear the jobs disappear and
you have vast
wastelands deserts in these in these
cities
where you can't have there are no
bodegas there won't be any drug stores
you're seeing that in san francisco
i don't i don't disagree with you i
don't know any democrat a lot i have a
lot of democratic friends and i have
several republican friends and we're
unanimous about
we want crime to go down we want people
arrested for committing crimes
uh the bell reform effort that passed
here in new york at the very beginning i
thought there were
things about it that made a lot of sense
in practice it's not working so i don't
fault people for trying things but when
they don't work you change those things
i think we've conflated two ish a few
issues here the gun issue
i don't disagree with you katie about
allowing everyday americans and we see
that
gun purges have gone up even amongst i
think we've some of the data shown
amongst democrats and people who might
be considered liberals and for that
matter people who want
more gun control measures people want to
be want to be protected i think when
democrats talk about guns someone and
we've had this conversation about ghost
guns and so forth i do think that's a
legitimate conversation and wonder how
these jesse quarrel with me saying that
these kids can't get fresh apples but
they
maybe some of the other things they
can't get but i don't understand how
guns find their way into these
communities but there's no excuse for
what's happening in california
gavin newsom is a friend but i think he
may be mistaken
at least with the the video i see and
the data i see there has to
that we should act about this and there
should be a change small businesses or
big businesses should not have to worry
about people walking into their store
and doing what these young men are doing
these guys should be arrested and they
should be prosecuted whether you whether
it's a small store or a big store
jesse well the left-wing goal now is not
to reduce crime it's to reduce the
prison population
so proposition 47 they called it the
safe neighborhoods and schools act
sounds pretty
and this goal was to keep non-violent
offenders
from overcrowding already crowded
prisons
but what it did was it just sent
property crime skyrocketing
and guess who bankrolled proposition 47
george soros they had only
500 thousand dollars for the vote no
side
and the vote yes on proposition 47 had
nine million dollars and a large chunk
of that came from george soros's
open society institute so they didn't
stand a chance
and 30 years ago you didn't have
left-wing ideologue multi-millionaires
bankrolling propositions to soften crime
and
da's to have restorative justice you
didn't have that all the money went to
governor's races
and senate and presidential races now
they're getting in the local races
and it's just blowing out because of the
cash
any opposition so that's why you have
these soft da's and these
weak laws so it used to be you could
steal
450 bucks and that was a felony now you
can steal
up to a g you could walk out of a store
with a 900
tv and they're not going to do anything
about it it's a misdemeanor it's like a
trespassing ticket
so a lot of these high-end chains they
have insurance
they're not gonna they have a no
confront policy you can't go and stop
shoplifters because that could end up in
an accident that could cause a huge
lawsuit
so they'll just write that off and
that's fine but a lot of these as you
said these smaller places can't afford
to do that
and now property crime is up and people
are scared
and they should be scared speaking of
the da's the left-wing funded da's i
just want to point out
kim gardner's office in st louis that a
judge had to dismiss
a murder suspect first-degree murder the
guy was uh
arrested on had to dismiss it because
the prosecutor never showed up she was
on maternity leave
and kim gardner just let it go and there
were three two other murder cases
dismissed this week
meantime the police are trying to hunt
down this first degree murder suspect
wow it's disgraceful that's what they do
these left-wing prosecutors hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it
anywhere else